in just two years this inept
Administration and of course their
climate cult they have nearly destroyed
the American dream for all of us here
with reaction former senior Council of
President Trump kellyanne Conway along
with Texas Congressman former White
House physician Dr Ronnie Jackson
kellyanne with 39 days away from
election day Jen saki is right if this
election is a referendum on Joe Biden
the climate cult and their failed
policies and how they've wrecked all the
progress that we made in the four years
under Donald Trump then they lose if
it's about all the other stuff they they
will fare much better which way is the
country going to go
I think this is the most uncomplicated
straightforward issue set I've ever seen
in three decades of doing this Sean its
rising cost rise in crime you still have
a lot of people concerned about
education parents say they have a
fundamental right to say where their
children go to school and what is taught
there we see what we see on TV every
night runs counter to what the Democrats
begin with Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
want us to believe they want us to
believe what they say not what we see we
see wild people out of control
arbitrarily committing crimes we see the
cost of everything going up and out of
control we see the report that one of
the fastest growing new groups of
homeless in our country are single moms
who have a job they actually have a job
a means of support but they get behind
in the rent this is Joe Biden's America
now the key to Republicans just
squeaking by with a few seats and maybe
a 50 50 Center or 51-49 Senate and
having a monster night is this having an
affirmative positive message that's
doable and accessible and actionable
that can commitment to America a nation
that is safe an economy that is strong a
government that is accountable and a
future that is free and number two Sean
to your point about Biden Pelosi Harris
and the rest
in Pennsylvania John Federman has to eat
and own all of his own statements he's
pro-criminal he's anti-fracking but he
has to be saddled with the Biden Harris
Administration same thing with Raphael
Warnock in Georgia out of Nevada Adam
laxalt has to do that with that female
Democratic senator who has three names
and no accomplishments everywhere we go
people have to be held to account as
Democrats ask Maggie Hassan who's
running for her political life or
re-election New Hampshire the following
question when Kamala Harris stood in
North Korea looking so foolish and
embarrassing an entire nation of Free
People
but at the DMZ she said she sounded like
she was on TMZ it looked like a
caricature ask Maggie Hassett if she's
comfortable with that level of
leadership but the ability to make every
Democrat out there eat and own the
failures and the flailing of this
Administration is the key to a monster
victory in a few short weeks you know uh
Ronnie between Kelly Anna myself we have
six Decades of experience and I agree
with her this will be the biggest Choice
election in our lifetime this matters
and yeah we can definitely point out all
of their failures but I like the
commitments with America because they're
pledging energy Independence they're
pledging to control the borders they are
pledging to bring back Law and Order and
Safety and Security they're pledging
choice in education you know them
they're pledging a better economy than
the inflation the recession that Biden
got us in so I think those promises
those commitments then they either
follow through or they don't they don't
follow through they they get fired I
think those are the principles that will
bring America back
absolutely Sean you're right we got a
lot of work to do I mean and we're going
to make that we're going to we're going
to fulfill those commitments you just
wait and see but everything Joe Biden
touches domestically and internationally
kellyanne's exactly right it just goes
horribly wrong and this man's gonna be
80 years old next month and he looks
absolutely horrible he looks like he's
going to fall asleep at any minute when
he speaks he slurs his speech he
shuffles when he walks he's a Blank
Stare he's shaking hands with people
that don't exist he's talking to dead
people now I mean this man is he's not
he is inspiring our enemies the people
that are watching this most closely are
Iran and China and Russia and they
they're inspired by what they see
because they realize that we do not have
competent leadership in this country
something very bad is going to happen in
the near future with this man at the
helm and the people that are enabling
him are going to have to answer to this
too because it is past time for somebody
in his administration to step up to the
plate and do the right thing and and let
us know what's going on there are people
there that have a duty to do that his
physician start with his cabinet members
Jill Biden all the people that surround
him the chief of staff and Susan Rice
and everybody else in the West Wing they
owe us an explanation as to what's going
on with this man and we need answers
because this is this is leading us down
a path of Destruction both domestically
and internationally and I really think
something bad is going to happen in the
near future because we do not have
leadership in the White House I I have
no idea I don't think anybody could say
with any certainty who's really uh
making all the decisions in that white
house all right kellyanne Ronnie Jackson
thank you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else